youtuber house tours youtubers so rich
but do they have nice house
today we investigate we're gonna
continue the list i made from last time
uh speaking of which after consideration
uh sniper it's e for sure
yeah and i think uh this man i forgot
his name
gets a c dar that's better and i think
ace goes down to b
and emma's house she doesn't leave it
anymore so she goes down a
actually a just goes down to c as well
now it makes sense
actually a's and uh doe brick is the
same but i don't like though bricks so
okay there
i don't like easy either i don't like
anyone okay what's the point of this
video again
anyway today we're checking out a couple
of good uh tours
first off we have nikolo who has
removed likes and comments on this video
which is always a great start
i appreciate her leaving it up for us to
scrutinize
uh nico is the tick tock
girl something i think there was a lot
of controversy behind this and i don't
remember why maybe scythe can show
some maybe i could just google it
actually story in three parts
why you delete your tweet coward god
damn it well i get okay
i guess she had t-shirt on that said
taxi rich and now she's rich
that's like water flowing through a
river it's just nature you're poor and
you're like everyone should share wealth
and then you get rich and be like
i work for my money get away lacey
scumbags
that's just laws of nature right there
all right let's check out her 2 million
apartment door 2 million bruh
hey i didn't expect you there come on in
hey guys look at my apartment what
what's the point of that intro
if you're just gonna cut to another all
right you know what let's check we're
here for the house about a month or two
ago that i moved into
a bigger apartment and i was gonna give
you guys a house tour
and i think our apartment's finally like
mostly fully furnished so
wait it ain't looking like it what the
heck
what
the editing is so bad cyber is cringing
to death
oh my god bro she didn't like
why are the chairs different they're in
a different height oh god
clean up a bit elgato lights on the
kitchen counter
oh god microwave is not properly fitted
they got a wrong one two million dollars
for this
for this this is what you paid two
million [ __ ] dollars you got a
laundry basket in your [ __ ] hallway
why don't you have two microwaves oh god
this is the worst one
i think we found we're gonna start off
with the kitchen um
i think i love the kitchen the second
most aside from my office i have a big
old island which i've never had an
island before so this is really awesome
we have the chairs so it's pretty
standard in a lot of houses at this
point
but yeah i like the marble it just
doesn't go with
i i love how i immediately just become
interior designer it doesn't go with any
of the appliances
and the color of the cup boards let's
get rid of it they don't match
get it out of my sight i thought she's
so messy i have to actually buy a table
to eat on
um we have this wine fridge which i
think that's pretty fancy a wine fridge
um we don't have wine in there but it's
fancy so
um well most youtubers have a wine room
at this point so
that'll mean nothing although i have a
wine fridge in my other house that's
right i have many properties
yeah it's great just filled with the g
fuel and drinks and
it's amazing we have our nespresso over
here i actually don't
drink coffee but like this is nice
then what's the point why did you buy
that i guess people
are very weird about coffee now i think
about it you tell them that you don't
have a coffee machine they're like
[Music]
[ __ ] you you're dead we're gonna pass by
um
our little walking area here living
walking
area give me your living room is that
your living room
it's the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life random box
tv terrible no cable management
do you see here or here what is this and
then r
just like high up on the wall and then
lights
and boxes is my brother's nest
over here he's just staying here for a
while this is not normally here okay i
just want to point that out
a couch will be here soon oh but even
then the couch would just stick out in
front of
this the layout makes no sense at all
are we
are we on board with this
we have a bean bag where my brother also
nests
and plays video games for now we have i
mean i'm sure it's comfortable but it
looks hidden
we're still exploring the east wing of
the house they so they don't have a
living room they just have like a little
nut of course
am i wrong i don't get it they have east
wing okay
my bedroom here's the living room so
first here
we have that bedroom the laundry room
as you can see there is laundry in here
so it is there for the laundry room
thank you i couldn't guess that from the
washing machines that's great
what a dumb unused space here above you
could have a countertop so you could
uh fold laundry but you can literally
just
fold it right wherever you made this
house
you suck and then this is the bathroom
it has a view of
the how high we are because
it reminds me yeah i was just thinking
like where where is she
how is this a two million dollar flag
that's outrageous
it looks so tiny in comparison to most
youtuber houses that
let me make that clear it does doesn't
it is this new york
this is a bath tub i never use by the
way i never use this bathtub but like
it's nice or whatever
i wish i had a bathtub i don't have
bathtubs
um
what is this what am i looking at what
is that comfort
it's so high up compared to the bed no
lamp
just a candle it looks like a massage
bed or something
oh what just go to ikea i bet i bet you
like this whole bedshbachel and all that
costs more than like a full
full room's worth of like a nice ikea
she then doxes herself by filming from
the balcony
it's bad this is all bad it's the worst
thing i've ever seen
yeah if i think that's the i i hate to
be so harsh
i really do i know people were mad for
other reasons but they should be mad
just how bad it is
f next up uh channel favorite
face rug the official reveal of my 10
million dollar house
full tour and a phase logo as a doormat
like where
am i hello is anyone home oh
yo yo
let's go hell yeah what we don't show
the house yet okay
my bad it's already time for the reveal
bro of course you already have a new
house
guys i'm gonna try not to get emotional
here but here we are
no no no just show the house just show
me
welcome
here we are this just looks rich doesn't
it it looks like hotel lobby kind of
like
luxury that's just from first impression
love about this house is how
high the ceilings are i'm always a high
ceiling type of person
so why why
why why face drug how how tall is phaser
you don't you don't need no tallest
feeling i don't know if you guys can
tell it has the caved in life
that's one of the dopest things too
because the lights come from the inside
which is crazy
that seems okay first of all that's
extremely standard
second of all having building lights
in a ceiling like that changing
lightbulb would be such a pain in the
ass dude
you'd literally have to have a guy come
up with a ladder and do it now we should
go to the dining room
so okay it looks again like a hotel
lobby
let's get real here you're never gonna
use the dining room unless you have a
family
you're not gonna use that room you're
just gonna eat in the kitchen
or wherever it's comfortable or
convenient okay maybe if you have
friends over and you want to play board
games or something right then i can say
but no you're not going to carry all
your now look at these chairs
like i don't think we could sit here
it's more for show but
this is say that we have chairs he can't
sit him
it's great this room is fantastic the
wolf of wall street painting look at how
giant that thing is
this is one of my favorite movies
everything about this is so elegant like
look at these glasses
this is more just for well someone used
the word elegant and others would use
the word trashy
i'm just never gonna use them but i mean
this dining room is incredible
one of my favorite pieces of every art
piece that she picked
is this louis vuitton pink champagne
bottle like
this is absolutely incredible wow why
why is it your favorite why is it
incredible i don't know
but he thinks it and every room you go
into it has the caved
lighting so as you can see there's
lights coming from the top
okay let's keep going am i there that's
standard
that's very standard face but hey it's
nice
i get it i have it too if anything uh
electricians just love putting those
[ __ ] things up there don't they they
just can't help themselves
what do they call this room like it's
not the main living room it's just like
the room that nobody really sits in it's
like
we have the dining room never used and
we have another room
uh this is like the living room main
living room but we don't use it
this is pretty lit i mean we got this
elegant couch
yeah i mean look at these giant chairs
just call it like that's a
cigar smoking room or something that's
what i would use it if i was a [ __ ]
that picture i think it's taller than
both of us combined that's a vibe right
there
and of course we have to get the gucci
in there we had to
god this like it seems like a parody of
of itself of course we got the gucci we
had to we and then we got the louis
vuitton anyway you guys couldn't tell
i'm wearing one of my favorites
oh my god they're this guy we're just so
different
all right drake of course okay
we gotta move on we're gonna go through
this door right here this is the room
that i'm probably never
going to use but it's the laundry room i
don't know how to wash clothes yeah
that's a
bruh why
i don't understand the logistic
this is practically a kitchen but it's a
laundry room
when will you ever need this mini
cupboard for
two laundry machines right am i what
what why i think if i had this i would
get one of those drying
cupboards instead you can hang your
clothes and then they dry really quickly
we used to have them in kindergarten
because when we went outside
and it's raining we would just have to
put our clothes in those cuff boards
and they heat the clothing super fast
and they don't wrinkle them when that
makes sense instead of just having
cupboards everywhere
and also this marble with that type of
cut board it just looks i i'm not a fan
it feels kind of dated
it doesn't necessarily look bad i can
tell that it has a certain style i just
don't like the style
imagine hide and seek so
yeah you can hide anywhere in these
cupboards man
imagine hiding it's crazy full bathroom
and shower every
single room you see in this house has a
full bathroom a full shower
face face rug you gotta get that you you
gotta get the japanese toilets
that's the standard at this point we
gotta stop kidding ourselves we're the
current toilet all right that's the
toilet of the past
we need japanese toilet all right if you
have a ten thousand
ten million dollar house you gotta have
a heated toilet come on
and they're really nice like every
single shower in here is super super
nice
okay okay i don't like the look of it
but it has to sit in place and i
i i like that it's a freaking movie
theater
oh are you good let's go okay
that's nice i mean if you have a 10
million dollar house you got to have
your own theater right
i hate the cushions i hate the color of
the green
but that's [ __ ] cool i can't hate on
that that's awesome i got a movie
theater in my house
and it's actually incredible it's
soundproof it has
art all around and my favorite part
can you hook up games with it though i
already know we got stars
oh that was his favorite okay dude what
movie should we watch first
maybe a phase rug video oh that's a good
movie let's put on the house
see this is how his setup room should
sound like instead of all these
youtubers that get these expensive
houses
with shitty acoustics because there's
just ginormous like
you need good audio quality i don't know
why i'm talking about this like it
matters at all to me
i'm just saying you have all these
practicalities and details but then you
miss out like the main point of
of your profession okay living room of
the house
there is so much to cover here but
basically we're gonna
okay i like that better
and my interior designer surprised me
with this bottle right here i never
really care
[ __ ] his blue label uh johnny it is
johnny walker
never heard of blue label that's nice i
never really cared to have a bar in my
house but the fact that
then why then why
it goes to show just how people want to
live this idea of luxury
rather than what makes sense for them to
live in we have this room that we don't
use we have this dining room where you
can't say we have this bar that i don't
never thought i wanted or like thought i
needed
like what do you want it looks like this
and you want to see the coolest part
like he's hyped about the cinema room or
whatever because that's cool but the
rest just seems like
look i have money this is cool right do
it
every single light turns on include it's
kind of an ugly
light but yeah sure it's good the bar
itself these chandeliers are incredible
and we got this cool hexagon design with
little accessories in the middle and
then we go into the
living room it's trying to like not
spoil the backyard
because like it's like an open door
scenery but they always fail on the tv
too i don't understand why they get like
the smallest tv
i get that it's built in but clearly
they built that this whole thing
like the tv could at least go all the
way right
it matches the fireplace better that way
i guess but man if i got a living room
oh it's like indoor outdoor i like that
and here is new brand new couch this
reminds me more of like a museum like
no heavy chains it's more for look so
the fact that i'm gonna make this my
home is incredible
this pool is baby let's go imagine all
the pool videos here
the water is always heated we have solar
panels
okay i think i've seen enough to
understand i don't know
i kind of want to see a setup like where
were you shooting we're doing that but
this is the master bedroom guys i mean
[Music]
it has an office it's going down what
does that mean it's going down or
it's going down what does it mean whoa
it's an
office we got the freaking phase logo
behind me we got
business meetings in here we got this is
our house
it's not useful i don't need it never
gonna use it just looks cool
all right um it's obviously very
luxurious i just
don't like the style at all it feels
like someone a 40 or 30 years older than
face drug would enjoy it
it doesn't have that young sleek
look to it i don't know why he likes it
but i guess he does
so i g c
d it gets a d hopefully face croc won't
make a video crying
i don't hate you face rug okay oh before
we move on
i need to make uh uh what's her name
this has been bothering me for a long
time this is the kind of stuff that
keeps me
awake at night so sniper will's house
is so bad so she had this couch right
and she doesn't understand why this
corner goes out
and i think i figured out the mystery
and i want to know if this is it
so dirty i waited six months
and look at it this piece does not match
these two pieces
and they still haven't resolved my damn
issue so she thinks she got the wrong
pieces but i'm here to solve this
mystery
so we got a straight on perspective here
and i think
that we can deduce one side is shorter
and one
side is longer the longer side we'll
call b side
and the shorter side we'll call a side
actually we'll call it long
shore long long short
long and then this piece is shaped like
that
this piece is shaped like that in this
piece of shape like that
what you need to do this is piece one
piece two this piece three
i think these two need to connect so
pieces one and three
you make them like this this is piece
one
it stays the same then you take piece
two
combine it and then what you do is put
piece three
because we know this is long and we know
that is long and we can see it's a
corner piece
so it goes like that i think she got a
corner couch
and she doesn't realize that's three
minutes too
so what she's doing you put this against
the wall
and then you lay a sniper wall here
on the sofa that's your cell phone i i
solved the mystery
what was i doing house tour okay cara
delevingne
did one recently and it's it's not
it's crazy it's insane it's bonkers
guys we've met before right hi a.d i'm
cara delevingne and welcome to my house
leo
come on okay i'll see you later be back
by ten
[Music]
okay
the design is insane everything looks so
picturesque
which is they've really shown here with
taking actual photos
one of my favorite places to be is kind
of like an adult dude look at that
ceiling it's incredible
i just think it's you know personally i
can appreciate the design
and all the thought that goes into it i
still don't like it but i can admire it
you know so we start off here this is
one of my favorites do i not like
anything yet
on the big big okay someone sell me on
this [ __ ] art piece i don't get it i
thought they blurred it out
for copyright reasons and then martial's
like no the that's it
that is not no stop stop
stop who made this fan of it i just tend
to kind of stand in front of it and
this is a joke right but don't stay too
long because you might start to
hallucinate
and now what sorry who's heard it
it's james tyrell okay there i kind of
like his work that's really cool
yeah i like it not hitting on the artist
but bruh come on
come on come on
get out of here no stop it
i'm a big big fan of it that is not this
is a joke i am
being trolled they blurred it they must
kind of stand in front of it and
stare at it this feels like oh it's a
james turnout but it's like the worst
piece he's put up
like he he got some cool stuff sitting
room
if you look at the ceiling i really love
the lattice work it really reminds me of
being outside
and the gucci wallpaper is also one of
my favorites and you'll see a
continuation of that around the house
this is one of my favorite pieces in the
room it reminds me of being in england i
don't know why it was like horse straps
i suppose
we have a beautiful fireplace in here
for the winter a rotisserie chicken
thing which i've never used but it was
part of the old house but i
it will hopefully one day be used when
i'm
obligatory uh rich people house tours is
that we have this
thing never used
that is a strong blue that's a bold blue
i'll give him that see that's a nice
marble too
i i'm able to get my family here for
christmas that would be amazing so this
is the kitchen
that's nice i love that color blue i
think it's one of my favorite colors
see it's her favorite color i wouldn't
have picked them and hey
at least she's doing what she likes this
house is very hard
floors so when you step on the floor too
much it hurts your feet
that sounds so spoiled and i know it is
but i got a little mini razor scooter so
i could scoot from my bedroom to the
kitchen
she's a charism a little bit crunch
yeah yeah i'll say it she's a little
cringe it's okay
nothing wrong with it i if i had to
psychoanalyze her i'd say she's an only
child but i don't think she is so it
makes no sense
i call this the games room this wicked
while it's
a see-through piano which i like to play
she just has that kind of thing where
she does something and everyone always
goes wow
because whoa no wow you can do that
but obviously as we come over here again
hugh hefner
is a big inspiration for this house you
know this is kind of feels like my
playboy mansion
i was very lucky to work with insane
details
my architect i thought about every
corner of this house and i respect that
but i don't want to hear her yet i want
to see the place so they have
so many secrets this is my vagina tunnel
shall i go through i'm going to go
through of course and then you're inside
of course the thing is it doesn't close
they didn't think this through
that you have a secret room but you
can't close it come on baby
i come in here to think i come in here
to create i feel inspired in the vagina
tunnel so i'm going to show you where
this lovely labia leaves
see you there look she can't close it
it's so awkward oh my gosh okay
that's kind of cool it was solution with
the laundromat that's
clever uh but you can access the room
normally so
doesn't that feed the purpose of the
secret room or maybe it's for
safety or something i don't know see
rebirthed and cleansed
again nicolo made that idea come to life
which i never thought possible
the davey bowie shrine so everything in
here is david bowie japanese puzzle
boxes oh wait a minute
hi what is a japanese puzzle box that
seems awesome
oh this is my bedroom every time i walk
in here i feel calm again
again damn it's nuts it's [ __ ] nuts
dude
what am i looking at kind of with the
theme of alice in wonderland i have
these like beautiful urns inside
i also have this wonderful piano by my
bed which makes me feel really happy
because i wake up and i just play
this bed it's obvious this is from my
old house so we just decided to kind of
paint it all white
so there's no way that's all the clothes
she has decided to kind of paint it all
such a beautiful color it's obviously
vintage oh it's obviously vintage
you can tell what do you think i had
some normal i know that's not what you
meant
but it came across this thing stunning
i'm pretty good at pool
so see see what i mean no one says that
no
i'm pretty good at pool she's an only
child in her brain at least watch out
everybody this is my favorite cue it's
pink
and then i like to just kind of stand
what i'm joking i knew that was there
that was probably really bad wasn't it
yeah you are a big cringe it's fine
anyway
this was a secret door i love things
like escape rooms
uh that was kind of a lot of inspiration
if this house was like experiential
so i thought anyone who comes upstairs
you have to get a different hat so yeah
it's kind of fun for every occasion
this is someone's personal favorite
usually people come and claim their hat
or people give me a hat
depending on you know which one should i
go for though
this is jonathan leo he's an artist he's
an incredible artist
uh mike said didn't like a wallpaper i
think it's kind of cool actually it fits
like a smaller bathroom
if you want to go crazy with it this is
also my
costume cupboard it's not wait there's
more car how many customs do you need
very neat but it's pretty cool
this gives me major twin peaks vibes
if you can everyone needs to have a ball
pit in a near vicinity it doesn't matter
what
age you are you know always kind of
maintain some sort of child like
innocence or joy or just the need for
fun
they're really great for stress you
can't i mean she's the self-aware of it
but yeah there is a very childish tone
too
a lot of it which i think is fine if she
that's what she likes
every stress i've ever had has just gone
into the balls the balls hold the stress
now
i'm a big movie freak so this is the
projector screen which comes down from
here
the sofa and you just get cozy and just
have a marathon of movies
damn that bar looks insane this is like
what facebook wanted what are goals a
lot of greens
obviously i like to drink delivery me
and my sisters co-own this
yeah every room is so like plate it's
like a playground
you see like one of those people like a
famous young or something
didn't have a childhood what am i
looking at like indoor outdoor area
damn i like the outdoors
that's cool another bar which is
beautiful
i mean i spend a lot of time out here
because i could be trampolining
oh no no one thought i could do this
with
prosecco but i can
wow you're so good kara
oh anyway i yeah all right uh
it's yeah cara cara house it's
impressive
it's actually incredible i just don't
like it which makes it seem like i don't
like anything oh i like
emma's i said that it's definitely
better than
brent i think his name was so he gets a
b there we go
the list continues who's next
let me know in the comments and i'll
check them out if you enjoyed
subscribe like and i'll see you next
time bye
you thought it was gay but true
relevance
never really died welcome to the first
undead game use any item in your
inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers our emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
who knows maybe i'll review your memes
the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this